human beings have accomplished
incredible Feats like climbing Mount
Everest circumnavigating the globe and
swimming the English Channel again and
again humans have shown their remarkable
physicality and will however there are
two places humans have no business being
the depths of the ocean and the Dark
Void of space as we've seen through the
tragedy of the Titan submersible being
2.5 mil at the bottom of the ocean
results in instantaneous implosion due
to the immense pressure by contrast
space is void of any pressure at all as
it's a perfect vacuum in this video I'll
discuss what happens when the human body
is subjected to such a vacum this is the
dark science of your body in
[Music]
space space is a perfect vacuum because
it's void of an atmosphere but what is a
vacuum a vacuum is an environment where
there is less atmosphere than the
atmosphere measured on Earth at sea
level at atmosphere is a scientific way
of saying gas is in the air the air
around you contains trillions of gas
molecules such as nitrogen oxygen carbon
dioxide and argon gravity pulls these
molecules down which produces a pressure
on objects known as atmospheric pressure
the force this pressure produces at sea
level is 14.7 lb per square in you can
think of atmospheric pressure being
similar to water pressure in the ocean
at the bottom of the ocean there is very
high pressure due to the height and
weight of water molecules pushing p in
down as you ascend from the bottom there
is less water pushing down on you and
therefore lower pressure when you're
finally above water the water pressure
is zero likewise when you're ascending
in the atmosphere there is less
atmospheric gases pushing down on you
decreasing the pressure once you're in
space above Earth's atmosphere there are
no gases so there is zero atmospheric
pressure which is a vacuum this absence
of gases in a vacuum can be seen by
dropping a bowling ball in a feather
feather at the same time normally gases
in the atmosphere causes drag on objects
especially on a feather which impedes
the rate at which it falls when gas
molecules are removed there's nothing to
cause drag on the feather and so it
falls at the same speed as the bowling
ball if there is any air retained in the
vacuum it will expand and liquids will
boil due to the absence of atmospheric
pressure we can see this occur in a
man-made vacuum chamber using a balloon
once atmospheric pressure pressure is
reduced air in the balloon will expand
due to lack of pressure if water is
placed in the vacuum chamber it will
boil as there is no pressure holding
down the molecules in a liquid state the
behavior of gases and liquids in a
vacuum is important because the human
body also has gases and liquids much of
what happens to the air in a balloon and
a cup of water in a vacuum is what
happens to your body for example there
are gases in your lungs stomach and
intestines the body itself is 60% water
not to mention there is water in your
mucus saliva and blood all of these
gases and liquids are held under
pressure on Earth but in the perfect
vacuum of space they're not the moment
you enter space without a space suit you
immediately begin to suffocate there is
no atmosphere or oxygen in space so you
have nothing to breathe in any air
remaining in your lungs will instantly
expand rushing out of your body while
also rupturing alvioli and lung tissue
hollow organs that contain air like your
stomach and intestines will be stretched
and possibly tear apart any fluids or
solids you have in your stomach and
intestines will be forcefully excreted
due to expanding gases within 10 to 15
seconds of being in space you will lose
Consciousness from oxygen deprivation
which is actually good because
everything else happening from here on
out will be horrific water in orifices
like saliva in your mouth or mucus in
your eyes and nose will evaporate
causing it to dry out when liquid
evaporates it also removes heat from the
surface causing ice to form on your eyes
nose and mouth with the human body being
60% water there is a considerable amount
of water in your soft tissues and organs
this water in your organs evaporates
into gaseous water vapor causing your
skin and organs to expand it's a common
misconception that your blood will boil
in space your blood vessels retain
enough internal pressure to prevent
evaporation of blood instead your blood
vessels will rupture from expansion of
oxygen nitrogen and car carbon dioxide
in your blood smaller vessels like
capillaries and arterials will burst
first before larger resilient arteries
and veins do within 2 to 3 minutes of
being in space you will be officially
deceased as your brain would have been
deprived of oxygen long enough for it to
shut down fortunately you lost
Consciousness in the first 10 to 15
seconds at this point your abdomen would
be inflated like a balloon and your skin
would be swelling as evaporation of
liquids causes a buildup of pressure
though blood vessels and organs are
rupturing and tearing inside your body
your skin may still be elastic enough to
avoid rupturing however space is
extremely cold with an average
temperature of - 454 de F due to the
perfect vacuum of space your body would
not immediately freeze similar to how
the coffee in your vacuum sealed tumbler
takes a very long time to get cold
eventually though your body will begin
to freeze and crystallize making your
skin inelastic and brittle at this point
your skin will rupture from internal
pressure causing all the gases to rush
out of your body as a result you will be
a frozen torn up dried out husk floating
around in space since there is no oxygen
to cause oxidation or bacteria to begin
decomposition you will float around in
space intact for millions of
years much of what we know that happens
to the body in space is from experiments
that NASA conducted on animals in the
1960s in one experiment in 1965 NASA
observed the physiological effects a
vacuum had on dogs dogs were placed in a
vacuum chamber where atmospheric
pressure was reduced from 14.7 PSI to
0.038 psi within 10 seconds of the
pressure change the dogs lost
Consciousness soon after their bodies
began to inflate as one researcher noted
like inflated goat skin bags and
forcefully excreted feces and vomit
after 2 minutes under vacuum conditions
most of the dogs had succumbed to the
vacuum environment when the chamber was
repressurized the dog's bodies deflated
back to normal upon inspection ice
crystals were found in and around the
dog's mouths from evaporation of saliva
and mucus though the dogs were subjected
to vacuum conditions the vacuum was
nowhere near the vacuum of space the
pressure in the vacuum chamber was
reduced to 0.038 psi whereas the
pressure in space is 1.9 * 10 ^ of -15
PSI or over a trillion times lower as
for humans to date there have only been
two events where human beings were
exposed to a vacuum the first occurred
in 1966 NASA engineer Jim LeBlanc was
testing a space suit in a vacuum chamber
when suddenly the host pressurizing his
suit became detached LeBlanc maintained
Consciousness for only 10 seconds before
passing out fortunately a test subject
in an adjacent chamber was able to pull
him to safety Jim LeBlanc was the first
human being in history ever to be
exposed to a vacuum and was in the
chamber for 30 seconds when asked about
the sensation of being exposed to a
vacuum the last thing LeBlanc recalled
before passing out was the saliva
evaporating off his
tongue the second incident of vacuum
exposure had a tragic ending in 1971
three Soviet cosmonauts Commander
Georgie da rolski flight engineer
vladislav vov and research engineer
Victor PV manned a flight to the Soviet
space station salute 1 the crew docked
at the space station for 22 days from
June 7th to June 29th
1971 on June 30th the crew departed to
return to Earth when the Descent module
detached from the service module two
explosive bolts were supposed to fire
sequentially but instead fired at the
same
time the force of the simultaneous
explosion loosened a valve that
controlled internal cabin pressure later
in The Descent this valve had opened at
104 mi in the thermost spere causing the
cabin to depressurize reducing the
pressure down to zero biomedical sensors
on one crew member showed Cardiac Arrest
had occurred within 40 seconds of cabin
depressurization the automatic flight
system landed the capsule 55 Mi
Southwest of kazol Kazakhstan 25 minutes
after
depressurization upon inspection all
three crew members were found deceased
the cause of death was
asphixiation autopsies revealed internal
bleeding from organ expansion and
ruptured blood vessels it was estimated
the crew was conscious for no more than
40 seconds after depressurization to
date the soy 11 space mission is the
only incident where humans have died in
space in summary if you're ever exposed
to the cold dark vacuum of space you
will immediately start to suffocate due
to absence of oxygen any air in your
lungs will expand rapidly as long tissue
is torn apart and rushes out of your
body other organs containing air such as
your stomach and intestines will
painfully expand as you forcefully vomit
and excrete fluids from your stomach and
intestines your eyes nose and mouth will
dry out and crystallize from evaporation
of water after 10 seconds of being in
space you will lose Consciousness from
hypoxia your skin and internal organs
will start to swell and expand causing
organ rupturing your abdomen will
resemble a balloon blood vessels will
rupture from expansion of gases in your
blood any blood released from organ and
vessel rupturing will also become gas
adding to the internal pressure in
ballooning of your body your body will
begin to freeze very slowly from The
Frigid vacuum temperatures if your skin
hasn't ruptured yet it will after it
becomes cold and brittle thereby
releasing all of your internal gases
finally your body will become a
stretched out deflated dried out husk
that will float around in space intact
for literally millions of
years sometimes science can be seen as
difficult foreign and even boring yet
there are times when science grabs our
attention and draws Us in yearning for
more answers often what draws Us in are
topics that are dark maab or terrifying
it's with the intention of this video
that you too were drawn in and sought to
have your questions answered thanks for
watching Dark
science